and then what about Kobe Bryant because
you had a unique you know ticket to
history in a sense getting to talk with
him asking him questions that a lot of
people haven't been able to ask him
um any surprising things on or off
camera or behind the scenes I know he
was at your event but any any things
that stuck out too about Kobe so he
walks in we had a meeting we have a
famous meeting if you you remind me I'll
give you the picture to put it up we're
in a boardroom and I'm sitting across
and he's sitting across from me we're
having a conversation together and he
says uh so it's pretty loud out there I
said yeah he says how many people you
have out there it's just 6 200 people he
says you're nervous I said not at all I
said you so now not at all I said then
it's gonna be great and yes I agree so
then you start talking to him and then
you see how he is same with Kobe maybe
even more with Kobe because what I saw
with Kobe off camera
is how he spoke to my wife
for how long and how he spoke to my kids
and how Dylan the day he died we were at
Seasons 52 when the news came out CNN
saying Kobe Bryant helicopter crash
fatal and you're thinking this is like
you know how sometimes these stories
come out of you're like oh this is a
terrible joke who's played it and then
they tweet out and say I'm alive this is
not a joke you know this is a someone's
playing a bad joke and stuff you're
waiting for that you're like nope not
happening this is what's going on and
then my son Dylan starts because Kobe my
friend so you know those experiences
because I saw how he sat there and just
talked to Dylan like he's a grown man at
the time Dylan was six years old seven
years old and how he talked to my nephew
and you know a lady came in a 72 year
old white lady came in and the way
because she was in town in Vegas and the
way they hugged each other and talked to
each other like it was his great aunt or
his aunt and
you know had no idea what the
relationship was with the two of them
but she talked to him like it's his son
and he talked to her like it's you know
but but you can see the love with
whoever that individual was I don't know
who it was and we sat down we started
talking about life we talked about
different things and once the interview
was up on stage it was like you know so
smooth because I followed this guy's
career
August 20th August 23rd 1978 baby I'm a
October 18 19 70 86 weeks older than me
you know when he came to La I'm a big
Shaq guy
that interview led to Shaq being upset
with me which he DM me what a stupid
questions to ask you know if Shaq had
your work ethic who would have been and
then he blocked me and then I'm like why
would you block me and then years later
I'm trying to get him to sit down and
then finally Shaq agrees to come down
for an interview and so Shaq comes to
the MGM Grand Arena we're at the event
there's you know thousands of people at
the Grand Arena waiting we're in the
back he says that was a stupid question
I should check that's not a stupid
question it's a valid question why would
you ask that's a shack how can that be a
stupid question and it's me him my wife
my kids everybody's there he says let me
tell you why it's a stupid question you
know at that time I already had four
kids he didn't have four kids he was
this he was that I'm already going
through this and I like to have fun and
I kind of got to do that we're different
that all this we're done okay fine and
then that relationship led into a
friendship where Shaq messages of my son
and Shaq talk to each other Dylan very
by the way Shaq's also maybe
um
yeah Shack is is a maybe one of the most
um likable guys off camera on how he is
and the memory he has you know we know
these guys as great athletes I mean
they're on the wall over there I got you
know both of their pictures on that wall
but
you know learning about these guys and
seeing what they did and what their
mindset is and how different they are
and what they you know during that time
for us to follow these guys the way they
did but I'm more interested on how they
are off camera and both Shaq and Kobe
they were 10 times more impressive
off-camera than they were on camera yeah
and was there any part of you especially
coming from La that is thinking holy
how did I go from you know being
overdraft in my bank account in my 20s I
never think you could ever meet them
yeah to them at your event interviewing
both of them you know are there does
that still Trip you out or do you feel
get used to it it's so so crazy you say
that so the the the easy story is to say
what yeah you know I would never thought
that this this is that but you know I'm
going to give you a different side of
the story I see myself as an equal in a
different industry I know this sounds
very weird and arrogant but I see myself
as an equal in a completely different
industry because the amount of
dedication it takes to make it in that
game I am sure takes the same amount of
dedication in different industry the
only difference is insurance is a boring
industry it's not a public there's no no
no no tonight uh Jon Jones out of
Minnesota wrote 42 different policies
and collected six watch the way he
signed this contract oh wow the
highlight of the top 10 plays yeah no
one's gonna do a top 10 place of
insurance it's just not going to happen
so the fact that there's an
entertainment aspect of sports that we
don't have in business and real estate
in insurance and Tech no one's that
interested on the entertainment side and
football and sports it is so at one
point I would have said wow but once I
was 30 years old and I kind of had
become a professional competitor worker
I I saw my I saw myself as equal as a
lot of these guys I love that yeah
[Music]